das Schwimmen nachts sind sehen Kopf
oder Ideen
tagsüber voll rumliegen am Strand
die Lieder die wir sehen die uns durch
den Sommer bringen und dazu deine Hand
in meine Hand
die Freunde die alles mitmachen über
dieselben Dinge Lachen ständig dieser
Größenwahn wildes knutschen in der Bahn
dann mit den Rädern in den Wald und Sext
er durch die Bäume schallt ein Vogel der
dabei zuschaut Ameisen auf der Haut und
irgendwann
und irgendwann
werden wir uns einmal fragen erinnerst
du dich noch und irgendwann
und irgendwann
werden wir uns einmal fragen erinnerst
du dich noch wie schön es war
ausgeritten
die Partys und das Bier betrunken sein
mit dir und mit dem dicksten Schädel
aufgewacht
und heimlich sagst du ein Gebet dass es
ewig so weitergeht und du glaubst
sowieso nicht dran das esse ich ändert
irgendwann die Freiheit das
Beisammensein doch dann fällt es dir
wieder ein das alles mal zu Ende geht
die Welt sich weiter dreht und
irgendwann
und dann
werden wir uns einmal fragen erinnerst
du dich noch und irgendwann und
irgendwann
werden wir uns einmal fragen erinnerst
du dich noch wie schönes war
und irgendwann und irgendwann
werden wir uns einmal fragen erinnerst
du dich noch und irgendwann und
irgendwann
werden wir uns einmal fragen erinnerst
du dich noch schönes war